bonsoir à tous et bienvenue d'un point
de vue ravis de vous accueillir ce soir
avec 4 des plumes les plus brillantes de
paris mais je ne vous en dis pas plus
vous les découvrirez dans un instant pas
avant que je ne vous ai donné le
sommaire que nous vous proposons de
suivre
aujourd'hui on les appelle désormais les
sortants ce sont les terroristes
islamistes et les radicaliser qui vont
sortir de prison d'ici 18 mois ils sont
450 est ce qu il suffit de les suivre
est-ce qu'on peut le faire et ce qu'il
faut faire plus vous nous donnerez votre
point de vue nous allons aussi parler de
ce délicat sujet de la procréation
médicalement assistée pour les couples
de lesbiennes le comité consultatif
d'éthique a rendu son rapport hier pour
dire qu'il y avait pas de consensus sur
ce sujet est ce que pour autant macro
doit renoncer à son projet on en parlera
on parlera aussi de l'iran benyamin
nétanyahou qui était à paris hier a
expliqué combien à ses yeux
l'iran était une menace et que donc il
ne fallait pas s'engager dans l'accord
sur le désarmement nucléaire que
soutient pourtant la france est si
israël avait raison et puis on parlera
de norman norman thavaud c'est le fameux
youtuber aux 10 millions d'abonnés qui
vient de poster une vidéo qui fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup parler d'elle
et nous aussi on en parlera avec nos
quatre invités bonsoir elisabeth lévy
vous êtes la directrice de la rédaction
de causeur vous est aussi l'auteur
derrien pense ans est publié aux
éditions du cerf on l'a vu je sais
maintenant qui est normal
voilà et da silva nous vous savez qui
est normal et puis on a vu trop
brièvement la couverture de votre
magazine qui vient de sortir
causeur qui consacre sa une à
l'antisémitisme
une idéologie anti française bonsoir
alexis lacroix
vous êtes directeur délégué de la
rédaction de l'express l'express qui
sort cette semaine à une couverture un
dossier de couverture consacrée à donald
trump et à ce qu'ils nous préparent
vous êtes aussi l'auteur d'un livre qui
n'est pas sans rappeler la couverture de
causeur de ce mois ci j'accuse 1898 2018
permanence de l'antisémitisme c'est
publié aux édition de l'observatoire
je tiens à dire que je vais dévorer
causeur car ce sujet évidemment vous
l'avez compris monsieur rené je pense
que c'est un dossier très intéressant
si elle est chère alexis quel concert de
louanges renaud girard est là aussi
bonsoir chers renault vous êtes le
chroniqueur international du figaro on
retrouve vos analyses sur le monde tel
qu'il va ou ne va pas tous les mardis
dans le figaro quotidien
votre dernier ouvrage qu'elle diplomatie
pour la france prendre les réalités
telles qu'elles sont a été publié aux
éditions du cerf et puis quand même
réussi là aussi bon soir karl ravi de
vous retrouver vous êtes évidemment le
rédacteur en chef politique du figaro
magazine s'est aussi invitée
régulièrement sur tous les plateaux de
radios et télévisions du pays pas
seulement notre et vous êtes l'auteur de
françois hollande le président du temps
perdu
ça a été publié chez stock et c'était en
je voulais reconnaissent aujourd'hui
dans sa tournée a perdu du temps voilà
effectivement et la place du temps
comme quoi le lièvre et la tortue ça
marche pas à chaque fois on commence par
parler du terrorisme et de ce que l'on
appelle désormais les sortants les
sortants ce sont ces individus qui ont
été condamnés mis en détention ou bien
pour des faits de terrorisme ou bien
pour des faits de droits communs mais
avec une radicalisation islamique 450
d'entre eux doivent sortir de prison
d'ici 18 mois c'est à dire d'ici la fin
de 2019
que peut-on faire et ton en mesure de
les suivre pour éviter qu'il ne récidive
écoutez ce qu'en pense nicole belloubet
la ministre de la justice elle était ce
matin sur rmc et pour elle tout est sous
contrôle
ces gens là sont évalués ils sont placés
ensuite dans des lieux de détention qui
correspondent à leur niveau de
dangerosité et quand ils sortent de
prison
il ya deux mots qu'est nous anticipons
leur sortie et nous les suivons de
manière extrêmement précise et nous les
suivons vraiment pas à pas alors
évidemment cette émission est la vôtre
vous le savez vous donner votre point de
vue vous vous exprimer sur twitter
hashtag point de vue hashtag figaro live
sur lefigaro.fr sur la page facebook du
figaro et puis vous pouvez répondre si
vous souhaiter à cette question twitter
terrorisme suffit-il de suivre les
sortants pour l'instant vous êtes 89 % à
considérer que ce suivi ne suffit pas et
on rappelle bien sûr que ce n'est pas un
sondage mais juste des points de vue qui
sont exprimés
est-ce que ça suffit renaud girard de
faire ce que le garde des sceaux a
expliqué c'est à dire de suivre ces
ex-détenus est ce qu'on peut faire plus
mais je pense d'abord qu'il faudrait se
poser la question de l'origine de
d'éléments et demi sur notre territoire
pourquoi ce que tout d'un coup après
l'occupation allemande
on a de nouveau sur notre territoire des
ennemis des ennemis qui viennent nous
tuer alors il semble que ce soit dû
quand même à une politique migratoire
laxiste à partir du regroupement
familial de 1964 c'est à dire qu'hier il
ya un paradoxe est énorme c'est à dire
qu'en fait on a on a décidé cette
général de gaulle soit qu'ils aient eu
raison de quitter par exemple l'algérie
qui était enrobé lyon du parti était en
rébellion contre la france au nom de
valeurs islamiques très bien pour
qu'elles se gèrent ensuite elle même et
que le adoptent des valeurs islamiques
qu'elle voulait mais on a aussi comme
ces pays ont été en fait indépendant
assez mal géré et on a eu ensuite à flot
des figures mais ça ils sont là qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec se passe comme ça
c'est vrai qu'au départ fait qu'elle en
quelque sorte une importation mais
maintenant je dirais que c'est vrai
qu'on localement ce sont en général des
jeunes concentrer à l'école de la
république
voilà alors effectivement alors c'est
ils sont allés à l'école là et pull et
donc il faut effectivement tirer
collusion d'intérêts la république
beaucoup plus stricte et qui apprennent
le roman national avec avec nicolas
public bien sûr avec des uniformes
c'est une très bonne idée à provins et
laurent suisse ce sont des techniques
policières je suis pas moi-même je suis
mauve un policier mais en tout cas s'ils
voulaient face à une situation aussi
dangereuse que c'est quand même
incroyable que vous venez dire 450
personnes qui peuvent venir nous
attaquer chez nous demain et bien déjà
en tout cas prendre une mesure je dirais
de salut public qui serait la fin
du regroupement familial tant que l'un
des créations n'ai pas réussi
enfant je ne dis pas qu'il faut l'az
avec l'arrêté ad vitam aeternam mais
heureusement la suite on voit bien avec
l'afinitor arnaud gérard qui n'est pas
une réponse directe aux sujets qu'ils
étaient difficiles et parce que les
causes et je pense qu'il a raison c'est
un aspect du débat effectivement ça ne
sert à rien si vous voulez de nous de
nous donner les moyens de lutter contre
ceux qui sont là maintenant qu'ils sont
repérés maintenant si on continue à
laisser les la fabrique fonctionner avec
cela qu'est ce qu'on fait ça alors que
moi je suis pas non plus policiers mais
il me semble quand même que le problème
si je peux le poser de façon un peu
comment dire peut-être exagéré ces cas à
quel moment on va essayer de respecter
vraiment nos lois c'est à dire une fois
que l'équipe sont il faut évidemment les
cuirs veiller en prison il faut les
surveiller quand ils sont en
conditionnelle disons quand ils sortent
de prison
à mon avis faut les petits chefs ne
serait ce que pour avoir une bague base
juridique pour les suivre et puis à un
moment
est ce qu'on décide vraiment de le
laisser dans la nature c'est à dire ne
plus exercer aucune surveillance moi je
serais assez réservé moi il me semble
qu'il faut effectivement on a des gens
moi je ne crois pas beaucoup à toutes
ces entreprises de déradicalisation
alors là il ya des expériences qui sont
menées je crois que c'était dans
l'article du figaro y avait un très bon
article qui nous racontait une
expérience menée avec 10 personnes
enfin où 15 personnes donc évidemment si
vous voulez qu'il faut les
et qu'il faut les suivre et
et il faut par ailleurs qu'il ya quelque
chose dans leur casier judiciaire qui
évidemment les empêche d'exercer c'est
pas la peine non plus qu'ils aillent
après dans la police après avoir fait
dix ans dormant donc il faut les suivre
le plus possible maintenant c'est aussi
une question de comment on affecte quels
moyens et comment les affects ça je
serais incapable de vous dire qu'elle
les avis d'internautes géo sur twitter
qui nous dit ne faut pas les sortir mais
les dés radicalise et oui même si c'est
compliqué comme le disait les habitats
l'instant maintient sur facebook avant
le suivi le gouvernement doit prendre
des mesures sur le terrorisme et clément
qui nous dit il ne faudra pas se
plaindre si une fois libéré il se passe
des choses car mu est la vérité c'est
qu'on est très démuni parce que une fois
qu'ils ont effectué leur peine
on peut pas détenir des gens à titre
préventif enfin c'est contraire à nos
règles de droit oui c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'en fait face à ce genre de
terrorisme on a l'impression qu'on a
toujours un petit train de retard
on l'a vu avec les terroristes qui sont
venus sur les vagues migratoires et là
on est confrontés à ceux qui vont sortir
et il faut savoir quand même 20 nicole
belloubet en a parlé ce matin mais à
matignon comme alizée c'est la
préoccupation majeure de l'année des
années à venir
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui je viens
en longueur ce sont des gens qui ont
terminé leur peine parce qu'il faut
savoir que les premiers condamnés pour
des faits de 10 ou de terrorisme
finalement les juges les condamnent est
à trois ou quatre ans ce qui était assez
peu et donc ils vont sortir aujourd'hui
et ils savent très bien à matignon et
l'elysée que l'effet sur l'opinion
publique d'un attentat qui seraient
commis par un de ses 450 là serait
dévastateur encore plus on le voit bien
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui ont commis les
attentats étaient fichés sont fichés s
ils ont déjà du mal à faire admettre à
l'opinion publique que ficher sc du
renseignement qu'on peut pas bon sylla
c'est quelqu'un dont on connaissait la
dangerosité
qui avait été condamnée qui est sortie
qui a récidivé
je vous rappelle que c'est ce qui s'est
passé à bruxelles en l'occurrence
c'était quelqu'un qui sortait de prison
et qui a essayé radicaliser en présence
est exactement la situation que vous
aviez
des cris hydrométrique sur lefigaro.fr
c'est sans doute un pseudonyme nous dit
il doivent rester enfermés
si nécessaire un statut juridique doit
être créée à cet effet des sortes de
prisonnier de guerre
alexis lacroix c'est là tu peux pas être
d'accord avec isométrique j'entends
l'inquiétude de la population il était
assez probable d'ailleurs que les études
d'opinion corroborerait le point de vue
personnel subjectif de cet auditeur
naturellement il ya une il ya une
inquiétude très forte
il ya un sentiment au fond de laxisme
généralisé
néanmoins je crois que c'est pas vrai je
crois qu'on est il faut il faut
réfléchir de manière là pour le coup un
peu philosophique sur cette question on
atteint nos limites intrinsèques si vous
voulez d'un état de droit face à cette
menace inassignable donc il ya quelque
chose et je reconnais que ce n'est pas
une réponse politique je ne suis pas un
responsable politique dont je peux me le
permettre
il ya quelque chose de tragique dans
cette situation effectivement parmi ces
450 personnes qu'on ne peut pas enfermer
elles sont libérées elles sont libérées
on ne peut pas les remettre en prison
sans motif valable d'un soupçon valable
de radicalité
il était absolument évident que la seule
solution réside dans l'accompagnement
policiers et deux points de vue là mais
naturellement ce que je pense que das
d'ailleurs l'accompagnement et
surveillants je pense que c'est la même
chose lorsque nicole belloubet ce
qu'elle met en place c'est un système de
surveillance rapprochée de ces individus
elle sait très bien qui sont extrêmement
dangereux elle sait aussi que certains
d'entre eux passeront entre les mailles
du filet de la surveillance policière
mais il faut qu'on soit bien conscient
d'une chose c'est qu'une démocratie
comme la nôtre un état de droit comme le
nôtre et je suis j'en suis un des
défenseurs ici sur ce plateau avec
d'autres ne peut pas se permettre de
substituer logique de guerre elle
logique de police et un criminologue
attendez j'ai patiné un crime et le lot
incriminé célèbre thébaux r dire que non
c'est pas un sermon dit ce type de ce
type de djihadisme de troisième
génération c'est une illusion de croire
qu'on lui fait la guerre
illusion d'ailleurs sur laquelle s'est
fracassée bush junior on ne lui fait que
la police ton clan faut absolument
renforcer la surveillance policière de
ces cinq individus c'est un sermon avec
les vivants on n'est pas en guerre
d'abord on peut pas appliquer le droit
de la guerre en france avec les
djihadistes à alexis alexis a raison si
vous l'aimez ce que je vois non mais
joe 10s alexis c'est pas à lui que je
pensais c'est que je pensais un papier
de libé ce matin qui ne portait pas sur
les sortants mais qui portait sur la
française condamnée en irak
si vous voulez on essaye d'agiter si
vous voulez les grelots de la compassion
de nous faire pleurnicher un peu de
l'ovaire pleurnicher dans liberty sim et
non non mais je vous parlais gbagbo je
veux dire on essaye un peu si vous
voulez de nous faire pleurer sur
d'éventuelles non pas entorse maison
disons une interprétation disons l'état
de droit pour hommes je pense quand même
que l'opinion car la raison je veux dire
il faut quand même être aussi faire
aussi attention les gens ont le droit
d'être protégé c'est quand même aussi un
droit un droit de l'homme
si vous voulez qui me paraît tout aussi
important que celui pas être surveillés
alors oui il faut l'expliquer le
problème c'est juste moi ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est la même chose que
pour la protection à quel moment et qui
décide d'arrêter parce que ça c'est
compliqué on sait très bien qu'il faut
pour surveiller une personne vous vous
devez savoir c'est combien de flics un
grand nombre un grand nombre et on peut
arrêter quelqu'un j'imagine que quand il
ya un danger immédiat et donc souvent
c'est bien il faut t'y policiers
effectivement comme disait l'autre côté
c'est pour marraine la surveillance du
colosse qu'on arrête camion marrant
alors jours à quel moment quelqu'un peut
dire mon celui-là finalement les tuiles
en jeu c'est une excellente question oui
mais on ne peut pas d'année en cachant
qui joue un double jeu la plupart des
théorisations pas tous mais la taille
pour tous ceux qui sont passés à l'acte
joue un double jeu notamment n'était pas
ne montraient pas tous les signes
ostensibles de du passage au radicalisme
et à l'islamisme et 11 ans ont déjoué la
surveillance trois réactions
d'internautes avant de passer à un autre
sujet gagna sur facebook et nous dit ce
sont des malades
il faut plutôt les internés nique sur
lefigaro.fr la justice et son laxisme
avec trois petits points qui en disent
beaucoup et nick qui ajoute que ce suivi
coûte trop cher la cicatrisation la
psychiatrisation qui est fait par des
gens aussi bien comme cette auditrice
qui sont évidemment des détracteurs du
jihadisme que par ceux qui lisent abete
éventuellement évoqué à l'instant qui
voudraient en quelque sorte dédramatiser
la gravité du djihad 17 cicatrisation je
crois qu'elle est profondément à côté de
la place des gens il faut en sable de
leurs actes mais naturellement un peu il
peut y avoir il peut y avoir dans une
cité d'erreur de radicalité jadis qu'ils
offraient nommé c'est pas la majorité
sur la plupart du temps c'est un an
c'est un embrigadement dans idéologie
merci pourquoi alors peut-être sur ce
sujet section hammar amant nous avait
dit qu'il avait été condamné à trois ans
et maintenant je suis de résidence
ouvert
dire en fait j'ai dit à bois il s'agit
effectivement peut-être pas d'une guerre
sur le sol français
il s'agit d'une guerre mondiale c'est
une guerre mondiale pour l'établissement
d'un califat islamique de la charia
partout dans le monde et c'est vrai que
d'un côté eux appliquent la peine de
mort généralisée c'est à dire simplement
si je me convertis pas à la seconde ici
choses simplement
je suis un infidèle journaliste
infidèles en irak une balle dans la tête
et nous on répond par au maximum trois
ans de prison la prison c'est pas si mal
c'est rare il faut comprendre et tu
n'auras pas ma haine
c'est sûr que dans une guerre et
commence pas comme cela c'est sûr que
moi qui suis un spécialiste des guerres
dans le monde entier c'est mal parti
on va dire que c'est une c est un
conflit asymétrique comme disent les
spécialistes de la guerre on revient un
autre
on passe à un autre sujet la procréation
médicalement assistée pour les couples
de femmes
ça faisait partie des promesses des
manuels macron il avait demandé au
comité consultatif national d'éthique de
consulter très largement les français
sur ce sujet puis de rendre son avis
alors la ville a été rendu hier et on
pouvait s'y attendre la vis et qui a pas
de consensus et que les gens qui ont
participé à ces débats sont extrêmement
intéressé extrêmement engagée qui sont
des points de vue qui sont très
différents et si emmanuel macron devait
renoncer à ce projet lui qui disait
aussi pendant sa campagne que il voulait
créer du consensus chez les français et
les rassembler en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'on ne sait pas comment il
va sortir de ce dossier
écoutez le professeur de l'oeuf récit
alors c'est le président du comité
consultatif national d'éthique et après
avoir passé des mois à écouter tout le
monde
il en est à se dire peut-être qu'on
n'aurait pas dû s'intéresser à ce sujet
tellement c'est compliqué regardez on
hésite et le même niveau du cce à mettre
à la fois la paix à mort et puis le fin
de vie dans le dans les débats puisque
sont pas des sujets de bioéthique
c'est des sujets des tic pour la fin des
10 de pma c'est un sujet qui est
maintenant devenu très bon voilà c'est
quand même un peu spéciale puisque ce
monsieur est président du conseil
national d'éthique du comité consultatif
national d'éthique si la paix est
massepain sujet éthique et l'euthanasie
je ne sais pas ce qu'il sera m'enfin bon
en tout cas apparemment il a passé des
moments plus facile dans sa vie
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire renault
gérard leu qu'est-ce que si vous étiez
président de la république que feriez
vous écoutez moi ce qui m'intéresse que
les femmes homosexuelles en l'occurrence
veille adopter des enfants
les enfants ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
futur l'avenir des enfants et de bien
les enfants et 6 des femmes aux
homosexuels veulent adopter des enfants
qui sont abandonnés ça ne me choque pas
at il à deux femmes
ça ne ça ne me choque pas et je connais
des exemples où je crois cette option se
sont se sont bien passées ces infections
un peu bizarre mais toute façon
l'enfant qui a été abandonnée déjà
lui-même qui est adopté déjà dans une
position difficile
et là on part exactement de la
procréation effectivement et alors
toutes ces expériences effectivement de
procréation par mère porteuse et c'est à
écouter moi personnellement je n'y suis
pas favorable savons pas mais moi
personnellement c'est trafic c'est dire
on va chercher une mère porteuse
ces voix là même si là en l'occurrence
c'est l'une des lunes des femmes
on va plutôt chercher un donneur de
sperme puisque c'est une pma sont alors
que ça fait c'est si vous voulez bah
c'est assez curieux je vais vous dire ce
que je pense mais c'est comme ça à
l'instinct parce que c'est vraiment pas
ma spécialité c'est que si que qu'une
mère ait porté un enfant avec à sperme a
connu un anonyme en quelque sorte c'est
elle qui l'a portée et qui accouchent et
qu'elle garde cet enfant en couple en
quelque sorte lesquels l'élève
ça me chante pas en revanche ce qui me
choque c'est qu'une autre femme porte un
enfant ça c'est la grc la gpa et la
vente voilà voilà les bonnes l'étoile
sujet soit là car mes us il ya quand
même 7 cette hésitation probablement
jeux présents dans le public c'était une
promesse mais ça va fracturé la société
française comme le mariage homosexuel et
il était très critique sur l'attitude de
françois hollande
oui je crois que s'il ya une boussole
c'est exactement ça c'est de faire
l'inversé de ce qu'a fait françois
hollande avec le mariage pour tous au
fond d'ailleurs c'était la première
grande brune bonne
réforme voilà exactement on verra
c'était la première grande réforme de
françois hollande qui a mis des dizaines
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
la rue et qui a crispé
une partie de la société ça emmanuel
macron ne veux pas vous l'avez rappelé
tout à l'heure lui il veut une société
apaisée
donc si on veut apaiser la société
effectivement pour peut-être pas faire
la pma et surtout la gpa mais on voit
bien qu'il y avait le temps de la
campagne dans lequel emmanuel macron a
dit qu'il était favorable à la pma et
contre la jcat et puis le temps de la
présidence parce qu'au fond vous
souvenez de son intervention
c'est sur tf1 je prends en octobre 2017
la fin de l'année dernière où disait
qu'il voulait pas imposer un choix de
brutalisation et donc tout est fait
aujourd'hui pour essayer d'apaiser il ya
eu les réunions de milliers c'était la
campagne aussi il avait il avait dit oui
effectivement il y a il a prolongé sa et
on voit bien d'ailleurs que c'est sans
cesse repoussé aujourd'hui le projet de
loi sur la bioéthique en octobre donc
c'est à dire que c'est plutôt un sujet
de 2019 et on voit bien qu'ils essayent
d'avancer sur des projets économiques
pour apaiser une société en disant voyez
on a relancé ça va mieux pour faire un
peu plus tard ce genre de sujets qui
sont un peu plus polémiques les points
de vue de nos internautes
nick sur lefigaro.fr la pma généralisée
n'est rien d'autre que la
marchandisation de l'enfant et il ajoute
la pma généralisée doit être décidé par
le peuple avec un référendum tandis que
amir sur lefigaro.fr nous dit le corps
de la femme est déjà considéré comme une
marchandise on n'a pas besoin d'en
rajouter
alexis lacroix votre avis sur le sujet
on pose une question très simple
peut-être trop d'ailleurs
c'est à vous de nous le dire macron
doit-il renoncer à la pma mon avis sur
le sujet et donc la pma et à l'extension
ou couples homesexuels ça consiste pas à
marchandises et le cours de la femme en
aucun cas c'est la gpa qui avec laquelle
celle-ci est souvent confondue mais tout
de même je vais dans le sens de ce qu'a
dit car j'entends des arguments d'un
certain nombre de médecins qui plaide en
faveur de cette extension de la pma et
je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'y entendre
l'idée que c'est une sorte d' étape vers
une libéralisation supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire par exemple la gpa donc ça
c'est gênant comme si
progressisme aujourd'hui c'était
entièrement réfugié dans ses prises la
de bastille ça me gêne je suis plutôt
pour l'extension d'un pma au couple mais
certainement pas comme marchepied ou
comme cheval de troie vers autre chose
deuxième remarque déjà eu sur mariage
homosexuel ce qui au départ était
régionalement sur un thème sur macro et
je vous le dis très cash parce que je
crois que c'est au coeur de on découvre
qu'il est beaucoup plus conservateur que
la fiche de campagne progressiste et
ruptures east de l'année dernière et ça
s'explique notamment et ça s'explique
notamment par la présence à ses côtés
l'un de ses conseillers écouter un peu
comme monsieur belattar ya monsieur der
wiel monsieur der wiel c'est pas
n'importe qui je ne le dis abolisse pas
mais il faut savoir qu'il est
politiquement il représente 7 moral
majority de droite qui aujourd'hui
essaye de peser sur leurs droits
vous parlez de tugdual derville so lu
ment et qui essayent de peser sur le
pouvoir
et moi je pense que ouais plus que le
désir parce que ma consigne avait aussi
des il y avait eu m'attendais pas trop
d'associations de parents même ceux
d'hervé macron c'est un diviseur aussi
je veux dire est beaucoup plus cynique
et machiavélique on le pense il et
diviseur quantique ans à la range
regarder le traitement réservé à
quelqu'un comme manuel valls parc sont
conseillés belattar donc il s'est
divisée non s'il veut pas aller dans ce
sens c'est parce qu'il a conscience
qu'aujourd'hui
politiquement il est soutenu par une
grande partie de la droite et qu'il ne
souhaite pas la cabre et c'est aussi
simple que ça les avec les wilayas de
location la question qu'est ce que j'en
pense personnellement lors la voie je
suis pas d'accord avec vous les gars sur
la pma et sur l'a2 la dangerosité
relative de l'un et de l'autre je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que la pma
s'ils voulaient la rencontre avec
l'autre sexe n'existe pas c'est un tube
à essai la pm là vous avez deux dames
dans leur toute puissance de femme et de
mère
et comme vous le savez si vous voulez
les hommes servent notamment à ça s'il
vous plaît à introduire un peu de
commande hier d'imprévu dans cette toute
puissance en lp1 peu de différence
un peu de 10 ans dans mais heureusement
les deux femmes dans leur toute
puissance de mer avec un homme réduit un
tube à essai ça me fait froid dans le
dos - ça me fait froid dans le dos et ce
qui me fait froid dans le dos en général
c'est qu'on continue et je ne crois pas
qu'on va l'arrêter honnêtement avec
cette folie de la filiation homosexuels
je suis moi je l' ai déjà dit je me
fichais complètement du mariage mais il
faut dire que l'homosexualité est une
sexualité non reproductive donc les
sociétés veulent qu'on passe outre cela
donc je crois que cela se fera parce que
la gpa encore là c'est à dire les mères
porteuses pour parler arrêtons avec ces
sigles les mères porteuses s'ils
voulaient où il faut quand même aller
aux états unis ou en inde ou dans un
pays lointain
la pma c'est à dire le tube à essai le
spiri spermatozoïdes que vous allez
donneur de sperme que vous allez
chercher ils peuvent être en espagne en
belgique c'est à dire et vous avez
d'ailleurs de plus en plus de femmes
seules qui en plus certaines n'ayant
laissé passer la date pour avoir des
enfants
elles vont finalement être la mère
porteuse de leurs propres enfants en
prenant une donneuse d'ovule et un
donneur de sperme donc vous avez un
enfant quitte en fait qui ne répond
qu'au désir dans un des individus qui ne
or la filiation c'est vrai c'est quand
même une question anthropologique assez
profonde et je commence à en avoir assez
qu'on ne la traite que soul en dieu moi
je veux et en quoi ça vous gêne les gens
pensent qu'ils peuvent se mêler des
impôts de leurs voisins mais qu'on
devrait dire que chacun paie des mômes
comme il veut ça ne va pas ça ne tient
pas je réponds très vite à la deuxième
moi j'ai l'impression comme l'a très
bien dit alexis si vous voulez que
effectivement macron veux pas
recommencer le skate la prod2 du mariage
pour tous c'est quand même c'était la
responsabilité de la gauche politique et
intellectuelle qui a passé son temps à
insulter les opposants donc ça je
comprends qu'il ait pas envie de
recommencer
je vais peut-être qu'il va faire en fait
comme ce que vincent trémolet de villers
on l'appelle à terre dans le figaro
d'aujourd'hui si je ne m'abuse et qu'il
va tout simplement attendre qu'il va
dire ce n'est pas bhl ce n'est pas le
moment ce n'est pas mûre
parce que sinon on va falloir quand même
fort à faire avaler aux catholiques
cette version dure en même temps je te
calinaud bernard dents et je te colle la
pma et rita nazis de l'autre côté donc
je sais pas si l'impression en soie
façon ces catholiques auquel vous faites
référence et qui dans la tête de des
macros pèse beaucoup car mâcon est un
vrai politique
ils ont déjà avalé le fait d'apprendre
que monsieur belattar et une influence
sur la politique de la ville et que par
ailleurs monsieur verville a aussi eu
nous occupe une partie de l'émission ce
matin c'est un humoriste que d'aucuns
qui ne fait pas forcément les vautours
de ce bateau voilà influents et qui va
quitter proche des manuels macron et qui
est favorable de telles mesures a
peut-être forme de communautarisme à la
française même si on ne se lancera pas
sur ce débat c'est juste pour préciser
les choses
prenons un petit peu de distance si vous
le voulez bien pour parler de la visite
de benyamin netanyahou le président le
premier ministre pardon israélien qui
était hier à paris notamment pour
essayer de convaincre emmanuel macron
qu'il ne devait pas soutenir l'accord
nucléaire iranien ne vous rappellent les
choses en trois phrases donc les
iraniens ayant donné en tout cas selon
ceux qui sont favorables à cet accord
des preuves qu'ils avaient arrêté leur
programme de 2,2 dans ris de
d'enrichissement pour fabriquer des
armes nucléaires
les occidentaux levet en contrepartie
l'embargo commercial sur l'iran ça c'est
la position des russes c'est la position
des français c'était celle d'obama mais
ça n'est pas celle de trump qui est
contre cet accord c'est aussi la
position contre celle de benyamin
nétanyahou regardez il l'a redit hier à
l'elysée
nicolas cage est ce qu'on peut entendre
ses arguments
renaud girard après tout les israéliens
ils sont quand même bien informée en
plus ils sont en première ligne donc est
ce que vous pensez qu'ils m'en mettent à
now quand il dit
attention les iraniens ne vous mentent
d'abord les iraniens vous a dit ils ont
donné des preuves non il on donne tous
les jours parce que il y à une
institution internationale qui s'appelle
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique qui se trouve à vienne qui a
placé des caméras partout dans les
installations nucléaires de l'iran et
qui filment en permanence ce qui s'y
fait par ailleurs en vertu de l'accord
nucléaire du 14 juillet 2015 dont vous
avez parlé c'est à ea a le droit de
faire des inspections inopinées où elle
veut en iran et là tous les trois mois
elle fait des rapports et vient d'en
sortir
qui dit que l'iran satisfait pleinement
ses obligations de non enrichissement
d'uranium bien ça c'est un cas voilà ce
que c'est un fait avéré et des 1 les
anglais le reconnaissent les français
n'en connaître les allemands ne
reconnaissent pas mal reconnaissait
kerry l'on connaissait il ya seulement
trump ne le reconnaîtra bien ça c'est
une ça c'est une chose
la deuxième chose c'est que monsieur
netanyahou dit que les iraniens sont les
islamistes est plus dangereux de la
planète et même moi je vous réponds
c'est faux parce que c'est vrai qu'ils
ont fait dix passages vous avez vous
parlé là je serai invité un truc ils
disent ici il dit que ce sont les
islamistes n'est plus dangereux de la
planète et c'est vrai que les iraniens
en dans les années 80 on fait des
attentats notamment contre nous en
france
rue de rennes
c'est vrai aussi qu'à cette époque là
nous chasseurs bombardiers étendard
bombardaient avec nos pilotes leur
capital qu'ils avaient été un peu gêné
par une autre action dont ils ont un peu
réagi voudrait mais il n'y a pas eu tout
ce qu'on sache au 21e siècle il n'y a
pas eu le moindre attentat islamiste
fait par les iraniens
on est bien d'accord les attentats
islamistes par exemple aux états unis de
2001 etc
ce sont tous des elfes on voit là sont
des attentats fait pas les non classés
s'attend à tomber je pense c'est un curé
je pense que netanyahou en disant qu'il
est qui les deux qu'il est je pense pas
du tout qu'il soit menacer réellement
par l'iran les perses ont fait jamais
dans leur histoire que libérer les juifs
c'est très clair tendresse et le gone et
alex frei c'est le prêter son ne pas se
le prétexte pour ne pas résoudre un
problème crucial qui est le problème de
donner un d'état mais dont on sait qu'on
sera les cinémas d'asie
j'aimerais ça parlait pas commencé chers
amis merci beaucoup c'est alexis lacroix
relativement c'est la parole à elisabeth
une chose
renault j'entends ce que vous dites
c'est pas évidemment totalement faux
mais il ya une chose que vous ne dites
pas quand netanyahou dit ça quand il dit
doter de l'armé nucléaire ce serait les
islamistes les plus dangereux du monde
c'est à dire c'est une hypothèse ça
c'est la première chose il ya une autre
chose que vous ne vous attendez vous
allez aimer c'est parler il ya une autre
chose que vous il ya une autre chose
dans votre plaidoyer pour livres que
vous ne dites pas et qui est absolument
fondamentale
ce sont les déclarations de la
mollahcratie depuis l'époque d'
ahmadinedjad pour rayer israël de la
carte
si on commet dire on réduit le débat à
naître de savoir qui va commettre des
attentats terroristes
on est à côté de la plaque il s'agit
d'un projet d'extermination d'une nation
je vous dis pas qu'ils vont mener à bien
il se trouve qu'à des paroles qui vont
dans ce sens et ne laisse plus à
attendait ce à quoi netanyahu réagit
c'est a tenu à une certaine continuité
historique et troisième chose je ne la
développe pas mais on ne comprend rien à
la position de bibi netanyahu que par
ailleurs je combat politiquement si on
ne comprend pas que la donne change au
moyen-orient et c'est étrange que vous
ne l'évoqué pas la convergence avec
trump actuellement la force absolument
incroyable dans l'opinion israélienne de
netanyahou ne vient pas du tout du fait
qu'ils ont décidé de faire une croix sur
l'état palestinien
c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils ont un allié
saoudien qui est en quelque sorte le
levier contre la menace chili tu es si
on ne comprend pas ça on ne comprend pas
ce qui a si alexis lacroix je donne là
je donne neuf mois et bien qu'ils font
des attentats dans mary en france ce
sont des sunnites
cependant pas des ginola l'arabie
saoudite merci chers jeunes je veux
donner la parole aux internautes et
ensuite cela donnerait à elisabeth lévy
et bien sûr à carl meeus qui reste d'un
calme olympien comme toujours dans ce
débat passionnant sur twitter on vous
pose la question est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec la stratégie d'israël
consistant à convaincre macron de créer
un front commun contre l'iran eh bien
vous êtes plutôt en désaccord mais massa
70%
frédéric sur twitter nous dit l'iran
n'est pas un ennemi c'est une
civilisation avec une population jeune
doté d'une bonne éducation
en revanche turing sur lefigaro.fr nous
dit les iraniens sont à grand peuple et
mais ils ont un gouvernement de brigands
rétrogradé intégristes et l avenir sur
le figaro.fr qui nous dit la propagande
israélienne est très forte pour aller
détruire l'iran comme on l'a fait avec
l'irak
elisabeth lévy vous avez la parole oui
alors d'abord je voudrais quand même
reprendre avec alexis ya quand même un
problème moteur renault à des clients
c'est que on devrait s'interroger
même si on s'en fout d'israël sur le
fait que l'iran n'a aucun contentieux
avec israël aucun en pense je vous
rappelle que pendant les années 80 que
l'iran était en guerre contre l'irak le
israël et est le deuxième fournisseur
d'armes de l'iran
il n'ya 0 contentieux donc l'obsession
israélienne de l'iran est liée
simplement l'idéologie l'iran et la
russie
le centre mondial de recyclage du
négationnisme un des endroits au monde
où retrouve le protocole des sages de
sion le plus facilement
et vous pouvez dire par exemple
l'afrique du sud at à ses mauvaises
relations avec israël parce que il ya un
passé etc
mais il n'y a pas une obsession sud
africaine si vous voulez pour les juifs
parce que soyons clairs c'est de
l'antisémitisme des temps je vais dire
que le pape orient soit un grand peuple
c'est peut-être c'est tout à fait vrai
mais y'a pas toi y'a pas s'essouffler on
n'a pas affaire à des millions de signes
à ce dissident on a affaire à un régime
extrêmement problématique
il est aussi problématique s'ils
voulaient dans la région parce que h et
l'iran cherche le bordel au moyen-orient
par exemple l'astuce ne se contente pas
il ne serait donc pas de il ne se
contente pas d'aider le hezbollah et ses
îles cherchent la confrontation
ils cherchent en permanence si vous
voulez la déstabilisation et la
confrontation donc il ya quand même un
problème de leur politique en iran au
liban au yémen dès qu'il ya un ventre
mou si vous voulez les iraniens arrive
et c'est ça leur version de la
realpolitik c'est de [ __ ] le bazar
partout
si vous voulez donc il ya quand même un
gros problème dernièrement saoudite et à
financer le bazar chez nous et on parle
de l'iran là est ce que je suis en train
de défendre l'arabie saoudite
non mais renault disais tout à l'heure
que vous aviez mcenroe de la politique
israélienne j'essaye de répondre sur la
grille alors j'allais vendre nour est ce
que ces patrons je regrette je peux
finir wasquehal et du lien des traminots
on vous laisse parler alors si ça vous
commandez nous vous écoutons et c'est
vraiment pénible ça veut dire donc 1
je ne suis pas en train de dépôt de la
politique saoudienne troisièmement si
cet accord était si extraordinaire est
génial il faut m'expliquer pourquoi
c'est obama qui a dû tordre le cou et
tordre le bras aux français et aux
anglais peut-être que c'est quelle était
la position britannique
mais enfin bon c'est à dire ils
n'étaient pas si extraordinaire que cela
je vous avoue juste la raison que donne
natanyahou sépaq l'iran au nucléaire ait
dit ça devient un pays de seuils et pour
israël c'est trop maintenant pour aller
dans le forum de renault je comptais
là-dessus je pense que le problème
natanyahou a raison de s'inquiéter de
l'iran le problème c'est que si on ne
respecte pas les accords que nous avons
signés c'est plus la peine d'en passer
parce que demain si on renégocie avec
l'iran sur quelle base on nous croire en
lui ni d'accord sur cette existence d'un
antisémitisme d'état
d'un antisionisme d'état en iran ça vous
paraît pertinent est ce que ça continue
à être vrai alors un l'antisémitisme
sûrement pas parce que par rapport aux
états de la région
le seul état où demain si elizabeth ou
quelqu'un d'autre voulez créer une
synagogue à teyran elles auraient
l'autorisation immédiatement d'accord
donc ça fait aucun problème des juifs
comme juifs en iran ou des d'ailleurs
chrétiens comme chrétien orient alors si
vous voulez ouvrir une église où
différents mais là ça c'est la première
chose
la deuxième la deuxième chose
effectivement il ya deux puis pas depuis
le cham effectivement depuis l'ayatollah
comédie
il ya une sorte d'anti sionisme d'état
effectivement éléctro pop dahmane et des
dieux les propos d'aminé giads en persan
d'ailleurs étaient pas il faut raser
avec des arbres il raye et ses propos
exacts étaient effectivement israël
n'aurait jamais dû ne devrait jamais
être sur une carte n'aurait jamais dû
être créée il ya des dire que beaucoup
de gens oui demain c'est à dire
effectivement l'iran comme d'autres pays
comme l'angleterre qui sait même pas qui
s'est abstenu à l'époque dans le vote de
la création d'israël l'iran paille pas
comme la france nous français nous avons
raison nous avons approuvé la création
de taille serait le régime iranien
considère que que c'était une erreur
historique de l'air cemaa girard sera
pas l'histoire mais non parce qu'alors
la prenant une demi-phrase une 2009
rassemblement de dire que ce que les
autorités iraniennes disent que en
revanche si les palestiniens
et s'il y est scellé les essaims ellien
s'accordent sur une solution sur une
ossature soin d'eux et a26 monastère
soir état multiconfessionnel
là les iraniens accepteront l'une ou
l'autre solution merci sinon elles vont
pas baisser pavillon
elisabeth lévy je suis en jeu je
voudrais tenir ma promesse celle
actuelle candidats reconnaissent que
vous écoutez chers amis c'est beaucoup
pour que je puisse passer la parole à
carmaux us qui aura un mot de conclusion
sur ce sujet ô combien difficile
oui mais c'est compliqué de parler après
des gens aussi éminent qui ont cet avis
normal ça me fait penser à ce mot de
talleyrand qui disait qu en politique ce
qui est cru est plus important que ce
qui est vrai et finalement politique
étrangère c'est pareil d'être là on est
dans une bagarre pour essayer de
convaincre netanyahu essaye de
convaincre berlin paris et londres qu'il
a raison et que de ce que trump a fait
c'est la bonne solution
je suis pas sûr qu'il y arrive parce que
l'intérêt à la fois de merkel de
maquereaux et de mai c'est absolument
pas d'entrer dans une guerre possible
ou peut-être probable il plutôt de
garder une sorte de croissance
économique en europe qu'il n'y aurait
plus il y avait une guerre merci
beaucoup cher car on va passer à un
dernier sujet qui n'a vraiment rien à
voir avec le précédent
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez norman
thavaud renault gérard je suis pas sûr
norman c'est une des stars de youtube il
a plus de 10 millions d'abonnés et il a
posté cette dernière vidéo dans laquelle
il explique qu'en mettant en scène une
des soldats sur un théâtre d'opérations
qu'il est très difficile au pouvoir un
possible de rire de tout sur internet on
regarde un petit extrait de cette vidéo
soldat laforêt derrière vous et d'en
déterminer les plus dangereux de ce
siècle
c'est internet notre mission est très
simple dans une blague sur internet
beaucoup ont essayé très peu en sont
revenus vivants religions ethnies
homosexualité féminisme politique jugée
sont très sensibles au mieux passé
aventurer
mais si la blague est subtil et bien
fait sergent le parlement d'un soldat
compris le ta blague
[Musique]
les femmes mais tutorat se préparer
jérémy ponthieu nous a rejoint jérémy
vous faites partie de la dream team des
réseaux sociaux sur lefigaro.fr
alors cette vidéo elle est déjà été vu
par 3 millions de personnes
c'est pour ça qu'on vous parle pas d'un
truc anecdotique enfin ça l'est
peut-être mais en tout cas c'est parce
que ça a dit quelque chose
pourquoi est-ce que ça fait autant de
bruit ce dossier alors ça fait autant de
bruit pour une raison toute simple c'est
que norman effectivement ça fait bien
des années qu'il est sur youtube c'était
un des pionniers est en réalité c'est un
youtube heures qui a fait beaucoup de
vidéo sur des sujets un peu de la vie de
tous les jours des sujets assez léger
et qui a un public depuis des agents est
ce qu'il faut préférer le barbecue la
tête de mon chat des vidéos sur l'effet
team ans lara clette des débats lors des
canulars au téléphone il est moins connu
pour ça mais c'est vrai qu'il a fait
souvent des vidéos voilà où il
intervient sur des sujets et il est vrai
que le point d'accrochage c'est l'un des
points d'accroché celui ci c'est de dire
pourquoi norman thavaud qui a toujours
fait des sketches assez léger finalement
dans lequel il n'a jamais eu à rendre
des comptes ou à se défendre sur ses
propos vient parler de ce sujet là c'est
l'un des arguments qui est avancé par
ceux qui sont en avant de cette cette
contestation qu'il assure cette dernière
vidéo voilà il est quoi il est contestée
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent mais parce qu'en gros ce qu'ils
disent et on n'a pas le temps de faire
des blagues si elles peuvent être
s'excite misogyne homophobe raciste en
tout cas considérés comme tels et d'ail
un certain nombre de gens sur les restes
ceux qui sont choqués en disant oui
c'est vrai c'est pas bien on se moque
des gens qui sont déjà discriminées par
ailleurs car mais il vous est très
présent sur les réseaux sociaux
rappelez moi le dollar sur twitter ça me
rend fou de jalousie
j'ai pas regardé la sabam et de 45000 le
constat de norman thavaud il n'est pas
faux sac
c'est vrai que l'humour surtout quand il
est un peu limite tout un peu
transgressif sur internet ça marche pas
très fort mais cinq ans plus tôt c'est
mal acceptée c'est pas accepter du tout
ça ne marche pas du tout bon nombre de
fois où en lisant un tweet ou en me
disant en écoutant un politique je vais
faire de l'humour est en fait il faut se
retenir il faut tourner cette fois
l'essai doit avant d'avant de tweets et
et on a plusieurs exemples de confrères
et consoeurs qui ayant voulu faire de
l'humour se sont pris mais des
tombereaux d'insultés parce que le
problème c'est que les gens considèrent
sur twitter facebook les réseaux sociaux
qui sont égalité avec les politiques
avec les journalistes parce qu'au fond
chacun peut écrire le même nombre de
signes chacun a le droit d'écrire la
même chose et donc du coup ça donne tout
ça avec aussi un élément qui moi
m'horripile à chaque fois c'est que les
gens se cachent derrière des pseudonymes
et ça c'est vraiment une spécialité
française et ça m'agace de voir qu'un
certain nombre de confrères et consoeurs
trouve ça très bien parce que sinon les
pauvres ils ne pourraient pas s'exprimer
et je trouve que c'est ça aussi qui
donne lieu à toutes ces insultes parce
que je pense que si les gens mettaient
leurs vraies photos et leurs vrais noms
qui serait peut-être plus décent je
crois que je vous donne deux réactions
comme ça sur sur à la vidéo de norman ce
n'est pas la liberté d'expression pour
les gens qui font des blagues sur les
noirs les arabes les lgbt
ce n'est pas la libération de la liberté
d'expression qu'ils veulent c'est
l'impunité un point c'est tout norman
sort du silence pour regretter de
comptes puissent pas rire aux dépens des
minorités tu peut remballer tes vidéos
alexis lacroix a un point de vue sur ce
sur cette polémique je vais vous dire
c'est pas c'est une polémique vous
regardez le son sang froid c'est plutôt
marrant la vidéo elle même moi ne me
choque absolument pas je pense quand
même un clin d'oeil il ya même un second
degré il faut pas je crois s'énerver et
prendre ça au pied de la lettre
néanmoins je vais vous dire il ya du
faux dans l'est du fis il ya du faux
dans cette dénonciation là je ne suis
absolument pas le défenseur autoproclamé
du politiquement correct à l'américaine
mais voilà mais je crois qu'il y a
aujourd'hui dans si vous voulez dont
dans cette voie là au fond si j'avais un
certain nombre de gens qui disent il
faut qu'on puisse rire de tout il ya le
désir de faire sauter certaines
inhibitions sociale et donc je ne vois
pas pourquoi ça serait impropre mais oui
je ne vois pas pourquoi ça serait un
problème je ne vois pas pourquoi ça
serait un problème qu'internet bridge
jusqu'à un certain point notre liberté
d'expression sur un certain nombre de
sujets relatifs aux minorités j'en
terminerai par là et donc ce que je sens
c'est que cet auditeur al absolument
raison il y a des gens attendent et il y
a des gens il y a des gens qui rient de
bon coeur à ses plaisanteries sans
arrière pensée il y en a d'autres
minoritaires 7010 existe qui voudrait
qu'on puisse à nouveau arrêté seulement
les guérir ma non je n'y suis pas je ne
suis pas pour la base'' louis je pense
et comment tu vas dire je les tiens bon
rire et quel est le mot vérité par la
police du rire sur deux principes de
précaution je pense que norman là il
fait lourd alex non il fait le politique
qui fait le politiquement correct a
expliqué à ma petite soeur donc ça c'est
rigolo
en revanche les implications concrètes
de cette démarche
je demande est forte a changé non c'est
pas lui mais je vais essayer la croix
qui vient de dire ça si c'est moi oh non
mais franchement ce qui est en jeu c'est
beaucoup plus grande que ça si les gens
ne sont pas capables de comprendre le
second degré c'est quand même qu' il ya
une sorte de déclin intellectuel et
culturel terrible ce que je vois c'est
une fracture générationnelle parce qu'en
réalité pour nous il enfonce des portes
ouvertes normal ça fait des années qu'on
raconte tout ça ça fait des années qu'on
pleure la disparition du second degré ça
fait des années qu'on n'en peut plus de
la bien pensante et de la chape de plomb
qu'elle soit sur internet ou ailleurs
parce qu'on peut plus faire une seule
blague que texte s'est fait virer pour
une blague que moi personnellement je
trouvais drôle en prise parce que les
mauvaises blagues ça me fait rire donc
s'il est on est dans un monde où il ya
une police de l'humour et alexis lacroix
que j'attendais sur son vaillant
destrier en train de défendre la liberté
dit qu'ils ont raison que ce que le
principe de précaution mais non mais
écoutez d'abord quand on voit cette
vidéo où peut pas ne pas comprendre je
le dis jamais eu de rigolo je vois que
là j'ai eu une partie de notre jeunesse
des ombres m'inquiète parce qu'elle est
prude elle et puritaine et maintenant
les lions y en
ça n'a pas du tout dans les jeunes
c'était mieux avant je l'avais je ne
vais pas faire la limite l'unanimité non
plus je n'approuve pas du tout mon point
de vue personnel juste une deuxième
point d'accroché sur cette polémique
elle vient d'une autre et d'un autre
point qui a été mis en relief c'est que
donc effectivement norman dit on ne peut
plus rire de tout et certains lui
reprochent j'entends bien certain sur
cette polémique là de d'utiliser en
rebours des de l'humour qu'il considère
comme désuet alors après le débat est là
aussi coin alors et justement sur les
blacks qu'ils considèrent comme aux
questions des femmes des juifs des noirs
des petits des grands des sur quoi on
rigole d'héroïne gold et gros des sur
quoi on va rire je veux dire mais en
tous les cas moi je pense si vous voulez
pour ceux pour la minorité disons à
laquelle j'appartiens je pense que ce
serait terrible qu'on puisse plus faire
des blagues sur les juifs c'est terrible
s'ils voulaient ya plus de monde comment
si on peut plus rigoler ensemble
et là mais termine sas je termine
peut-être en apportant un contraste à ça
c'est qu'il est vrai que si l'on s'en
fie aux commentaires de la vidéo il y a
eu aussi un soutien dans l'autre sens en
verre norman il faut pas non plus c'est
vrai forcément que l'ongle il ya eu un
angle qui ne pourraient polémique qui
est qui naquit de ça beaucoup de
discussions il y en a aussi qui
justement prennent le parti de dire il
faut rire de tout et certains autres qui
leur disent voilà il faut rire de tout
mais pas avec tout du moins cher rené
girard maintenant que vous savez qui est
normal et bien je vais sur ce sujet
alors moi j'ai envie de dire
l'idée des journaux lisez des livres
fermer les boutiques de fringues rouvre
les librairies aller au lycée fait la
cagne voilà est effectivement tout ce
monde de la rapidité de l'internet du
message twitter j'ai quarante cinq mille
quarante cinq mille quatre cent
cinquante mille ou quatre millions et
demi et je hais je twitte pour voir qui
me suit tout fameux centre pathétique
youtube youtube youtube c'est rossi
alors la séance est ben oui et bat pour
toi moi je ne suis pas réac du tout je
vais juste un mot ce jeudi juste un mois
par joue pas sa parole pour dire que
youtube c'est aussi un des supports qui
diffuse point de vue et qui permet à
tous nos internautes comme twitter
d'avoir accès aux analyse passionnante
de renaud girard et quart mais je
rajoute juste un bémol c'est que le
figaro et l'express sont sur twitter et
ont plusieurs millions d'abonnés donc
comme quoi malgré tous ces réseaux c'est
sûr que vous ne pouvez trouver
pathétique magnum sont pas tant que ça
si c'est purement subjectif ça n'engage
que moi ça n'empêche pas mon journal il
ya un courant de pensée dont je serai
elle porte à titre personnel je suis
comme girard c'est à dire que la fuite
en avant dans l'exhibition de soi pour
gagner les suffrages électronique
ça ne m'a jamais excité et j'allais dire
ce même ça me fait un peu peur donc sur
des réseaux sociaux j'en suis très
content les jolies escompté légalisant
qu'étrangère
unification je suis je suis je j'utilise
et je trouve ça très pratique
effectivement les sms comme tout le
monde et même on peut très bien diffuser
des messages des messages très attendu
sur scène et sur facebook
et comme je suis le premier à me réjouir
de google mais je considère que
l'édification d'une politique étrangère
à coup de messages de 140 2 ou 146
caractère est une régression pas têtus
que ça c'est notre message c'est un
message personnel de cette émission est
tard vous avez dix voire vingt secondes
très rapidement juste pour dire
effectivement que sur youtube aurait
aussi vous intéresser à d'autres
créateurs et sur le figaro on en a parlé
à traire les créatures du web une série
qu'on a voulu retrouver on s'intéresse à
des créateurs qui ne parlent pas
forcément ça sort sur saignement et je
termine par un message personnel j'ai
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins de 10 fois
moins de followers sur twitter que carl
meeus c'est pour moi un motif
d'insatisfaction très fort donc si vous
venez me rejoindre n'hésitez pas dans
l'émission sa qualité ou la quantité
l'émission est terminée et puis je il ya
aussi turing qui s'est exprimé à qui
j'ai pas encore donné la parole alors
que il nous donne son avis sur
lefigaro.fr tout le monde s'exprime sur
internet de façon anonyme il est donc
bien difficile de séparer le bon grain
de l'ivraie
et bien c'est sur ce commentaire plein
de sagesse et de justesse que se termine
cette émission merci beaucoup de l'avoir
suivi point de vue revient demain même
heure même endroit
bonsoir à tous
[Musique]